there is so much BS all across YouTube
from famous gurus books personal
development books and I personally
believe that there's a lot of
information in there that are nonsense
and there's certain authors and certain
speakers that you should probably stop
watching as we move into 2024 so what
I'm going to be doing right now is I'm
going to be giving a list of all the
cliche personal development nonsense and
discussing with my brother Mr CEO
Russell Leeds and we might disagree on
some of these points I'm very interested
I know some of them we've discussed
previously and I want to know what you
think what do you think of these uh of
these slogans what do you think of these
cliches do you agree with them do you
disagree the first one and I've seen
whole books written about this and I
think it's absolute nonsense and I hear
it over and over and over again people
saying oh always be closing what do you
think in business when you're doing a
sale sat down trying to sell something
what do you think about the always be
closing slogan I I think that it's
nonsense it is nonsense why is it
nonsense the reason it's nonsense is
because you shouldn't always be closing
you you should close when it's time to
close people that will always be closing
type people they're the ones that come
up to you at networking events and try
and force that product down your down
your throat and it's like you shouldn't
be trying to sell to someone well you
should not even trying to sell you
shouldn't be trying to close someone who
you haven't sold to you hav qualifi it's
just it's just stupid absolute BS have
you read the book or always be closing
no I not either
because I was disgusted at the title but
I'd be very interested no I don't know
if I would be interested in reading the
book but a lot of people do it and I see
people trying do it on me some do
they'll go to networking events as you
said they should just be relaxed
collecting business cards growing their
list and marketing and they're closing
then on a sales call they've got some
they've got a property deal they want to
sell and then they just trying to sell
it too quick no no no ask questions
listen close and before you close you
should pre-close yeah nonsense and and
you should there's L lots of steps
before the close right loads of steps so
all to always be closing like in a
boxing match always throw a big right
hook what yeah no nonsense next people
do business with those that they know
like and Trust nonsense go on explain to
me why it's nonsense because it's not
true who is your phone provider e e do
you like them not really no do you even
know who the founder is when it says no
though does it mean know the company or
know the do you know them are you famili
do you feel like you're familiar or do
they I I don't even know who I'm with
sometimes I have to check I know the you
feel like you know you got a
relationship with you got got nice Rel
got relationship with him okay so you
not got a relationship there's no like
there's no there's no familiarity there
just trust e trust them got you back I
don't no I got back right so you don't
know them you don't like them you don't
trust them but you've been you've been
their customer giving them money not
just you giveing them money every single
member of our of our company is with e
because we pay for their phones and
laptops and what whatever whatever it's
just nonsense I think people do BS with
those that they have they get value from
I do agree with you on that it's
absolute nonsense do you know the kind
of nonsense that is go and have seven
cups of coffee with somebody and build
up relationships and it's just a waste
of time that the biggest problem people
have in their life is trying to be liked
by everybody if you're trying to be
liked you're trying to be liked known
and it's got you've got to be good youve
got to be successful you got to Brand
yourself well think absolute nonsense I
learned that at BNI BNI business Network
Internationals there's a lot of good
stuff there I learned but this one i'
honestly think it's just do you think
when they say no do you think they mean
you know the brand so like for example
if you see an ad for something and you
you've never heard of the brand all the
company that are selling it you're much
less likely to buy because but this is
said to entrepreneurs isn't it it's it's
it's known be known yeah but it's not
about being being well branded being
well positioned this is used as like
build build someone that you know and
it's nonsense I agree next one's
nonsense is the whole thing about unique
selling point find your USP your unique
selling point do you know what's funny
about the USP I totally agree with you
on it being nonsense why is it accepted
mainstream but not only that when you
first started I bet you were told
everyone says it you need to find your
USP and I bet you spent time when you
your early businesses trying to think
what is my how I unique yeah how's my
business going to be unique when it
shouldn't be unique in fact do you know
what the definition of a unique is
there's nothing else in the world like
it correct there's nothing else in the
world like it completely unique I see
people trying to be unique with service
accommodation and they'll be like Oh I'm
going to I'm going to do a hotel for dog
walkers in this little town where there
is no hotels no one's doing it you know
I'll be the first and I'm like yeah and
you'll be the last yeah because I see I
also don't like the Gap in the market no
there's a gap in the market yeah do you
know why cuz it doesn't work yeah
there's a gap in the market but is there
a market in the Gap that's the question
and there often isn't cuz if it worked
in that town and there was loads of dog
workers there'd be someone already doing
it when someone's already doing it it's
like okay there's a market for it it's
like the arrogance to think that you out
of the 7 billion people in the world
you're the one that's thought of the
idea there's nothing unique about your
idea King Solomon says there is nothing
new Under the Sun so I believe in
copying and pasting finding someone
that's doing something well finding an
idea Market copying and pasting it or or
maybe tweaking it improving people say
oh that's saturated there's too many
deal sources it's saturated you know
what there's lots of deal sources
because there's so many investors
looking for deal sources looking to buy
deal saturated nonsense poor broken
mentality if there's 10,000 people doing
it in the city of Birmingham you just
got to be a little bit better there's
obviously a lot of supp um uh Supply but
there's also a lot of demand You' be a
little bit better than the 10,000 You'
be in the top 10% and you're going to
clean up because the amount of demand
that there is mentality people give
examples of where there is a gap in the
market but you could probably C them on
like one hand the new Innovations and
stuff another one I don't believe in is
I don't believe in work life work life
balance work life balance uh sucks it
doesn't make sense it doesn't exist I
mean work life balance indicates that
work is not
life right for a you got your work and
then you got your life and you're trying
to balance the two it's just absolute
nonsense another one I don't believe in
this one's going to be really
controversial I don't believe in how you
do anything is how you do everything I I
strongly don't agree with that is
nonsense I know that from my personal
own perspective did you ever believe
that yes when did you believe it when I
was told it over and over in every
single personal development book and I
just thought oh it must be true cuz
everyone's saying it yeah what you mean
just stop and think about it though
there's when you become success here's
the thing right when you become
successful you then realize a lot of
what you learned from books was nonsense
is it possible that thinking for example
how you do anything cuz how you do
everything having that in your when when
you when you were getting started helped
you to become successful because it
pushed you to do everything it's just
it's just not true though it isn't true
I think it's true in some contexts and I
do get it and I'll even say it sometimes
because I think that if I say it in the
context I'm saying it it's true for
example if I'm running a training
program and there's people in the room
that are not really playing full out and
and I'm saying right everyone pick up
the phone ring an agent and there's
people say I'm not I'll do it next week
no you won't how you do anything how you
do everything if you don't do it here
you won't do it there in that context
but but that's not how you do anything
how you do everything that's how you do
it now is how you're going to do it out
there it's true it's the same thing all
right this this one's going to be
controversial now I'll probably hated
for this but it be interesting to see if
you agree I'm I'm confident you would
agree cuz I think we've spoken about
this and that is when people are
building a business and they're making
money and you see a lot of successful
people on YouTubers and podcasts and
they asked what's your reason why you
doing this and they say what do they say
oh you know what you're going to say
what am I going to say they're going to
say uh for my kids I'm doing it for my
kids and you know what I don't believe
them no nor I don't believe anybody that
says they didn't it for their kids it is
nonsense you know what why I'm building
my business not for my kids go on
obviously do it's not it's not for my
kids yeah it's cuz I just like winning I
enjoy winning I want to leave a legacy I
want to be the best version of myself
I'm not do for my kids here's here's the
thing though right so we had I won't
know who it is but we had a successful
person who was on we interviewed uh
recently and they said they were doing
it for their kids but their kids like
two and they've been doing it for 10
years so what what were they do so what
drove you then the eight years before
your kid was born with just the fact
that one day your kid they'd say that
though they're so deep rooted in the
light they'd say I was doing it because
I knew that I was going to have a kid
kid one day and I was doing it for my
unborn kids I'll tell you why you're not
doing it for your kids the reason you're
not doing it for your kids is because if
you were doing it for your kids you
would get to a certain level and then
you would stop and you would say I've
achieved enough now if I if my real
reason is to do for my kids and I will
now spend time with my kids here's the
thing right our property business makes
about 150 Grand a month passive income
it's an excuse right what's an excuse
it's when they say they're doing it for
their kids it's an excuse right but
here's the thing we're making about 150
Grand a month passive income from our
property business on top of that we're
doing development we're doing training
programs we right if we retired tomorrow
our kids their life financially their
private school home school blah blah
blah exact same yeah they're completely
set we've got millions and millions of
pounds in trusts and the trusts are set
up to go to the kids they don't need any
more money at all ever to say but we're
pushing forward to continue going to
business for our kids is disingenuous
and wrong do you think this where I do
think is true where certain people are
like in on the poverty line and they may
be working an extra job to send their
kids to college for example maybe or
maybe if they're working 50 hours a week
in a job they don't like and they're
starting a property business or
something to get out of their job to
spend more time with their kids I
believe that yeah I I don't believe it
where people are already Millionaires
and they're making many many millions
and they're pretending their kids are
their reason do you think they believe
it I don't think they know what their
real reason is and it just sounds good
so they just say it I don't I don't do
you think their spouse believes it do
you think that do you think it's like an
excuse to to to the partner oh the
reason I'm I'm putting all these hours
working so hard is it's you know it's
for it's not for your family it's not
for your kids
for you it's for your sense of
fulfillment it's your it's greatness the
feeling of being great the feeling of
being the best the feeling of is is a
good feeling not I'm doing it for my
kids leaving millions and millions of
pounds for your kids giving them loads
of money everything they ever wanted you
can just click and give it to it's not
going to do them any favors anyway no
it's not it's actually if anything it's
going to make it you they say don't they
like strong times make weak men no it's
the opposite no strong times make weak
men no strong times make tough men
strong times we've got the saying wrong
here we no you got the same wrong and
then you freak me out but you tough
times create tough people tough times
create times create weak people if you
making it too easy this that we've
talked about as well not make it too
easy I'll make my kids fly economy
exactly so if anything you don't want to
give them too much because then they
won't be able to they w't have the same
drive to go and do anyway so if anything
it's just a nonsense cliche isn't it we
do for our kids it's just nonsense all
right what about um Health before wealth
I don't believe that I think that's BS I
think Health before wealth it depends
what it means so it in the context it's
mostly used everybody says it I'll post
a picture of me looking healthy and
they'll all be like Health before wealth
Health before wealth I don't argue with
them because they're coming from a good
place but it's nonsense the bottom line
is business comes first it it is true in
terms of always no it is true it is
Health before wealth cuz if I said to
you u i now I don't agree with the
context it's used in which I'm sure what
we saying but if I said to you would you
rather be permanently sick and be a
billionaire oh or be broky but be fit
what would you choose oh man obviously I
would right so the health so the health
is before wealth however yes it is yes
it is no that's like saying no he'd
rather be a millionaire
multi-millionaire right but dead which
is the ultimate not no Health obviously
I'd Rather Be Alive well life before
money what the what are you talking
about life before money it's just
nonsense stupid list listen you would
choose your if you had no health of
course you would right so health is
before Health however the contents that
is used in is and it's very similar with
family first by the way which I which
very similar which also irritates me a
little bit even though it's true but
this is the thing if you say oh I know
I've got this really important business
meeting but I've got a gym appointment
i' have to skip the business meeting you
be an idiot because why because business
comes first always so yeah and anyone
that disagrees is broke they are or
they're lying because I I tell you
something and I I'll upset people saying
this cuz I'm no no gym first gym first
you only need to spend 45 minutes a day
day working out if you're working out
like how I work out properly working out
for day you're going to be real fit but
to build a big business you need 10 15
hours a day so to prioritize your gym
session over it's just nonsense you can
do that in in your nooks and crannies of
Life business first business needs to be
the thing that you you you're immersed
in then you do use bits of BS of Fitness
on the side would you agree with that I
I do agree with that another one that's
nonsense is patience be patient tell me
this one be patient is nonsense it's
nonsense the Bible though isn't it quote
the verse goodness kindness patience
gentleness self control the fruits of
the spirit and one of those patience
yeah cool I'm not saying patience is but
you just said your whole phrase was be
patient he says [__] yeah it's
nonsense in the context of building a
business I don't agree with it of course
it's a patience is a that's that's the
verse patience is a virtue of course you
need to be patient if your kid's been
irit irritating you got to be patient
with your kid absolutely I'm not saying
I don't think patience is every time
what I'm talking about I'm explain I'm
talking about you should get things done
quick I'm an extremely impatient
impulsive business person and that's why
I'm so successful this idea of patience
just breeds normality and average and
just wait be Millionaire Next Door one
day don't drink Starbucks don't watch
Netflix and just be patient and then
when you're 67 you'll be a millionaire
what I just don't agree with it I just
think get it now get live life now get
it fast but but even but however patient
or impatient you are you always feel
slower and when you look back and you
real like I saw your post the other day
on in 2023 I've achieved blah blah blah
do you know why I achieved so much in
2023 cuz I'm impatient which brings me
to my next point which is also nonsense
which is a 10year plan it's just
absolute nonsense I'm sorry I'm probably
I've just probably just SP myself the
most hated YouTuber ever but I tell you
something I tell you why 10 year plan's
rubbish I I agree I'm just going to say
this though come back to me every
listener that's upset when you are worth
20 mil and tell me then that I was wrong
don't tell me that I'm wrong until
you've made millions of pound when
you're making a million pound a month
which I make actually I don't make a
million pound a month I add tell them my
finance director made a mistake right
yeah and said I said how much how when
we were going through the the finance
report and it said that we' made just
over a million pounds in a month and I I
almost had heart attack like ah we only
made 1.1 million what the crap is going
on and then oh sorry I missed this
Revenue here that we've got it was
actually 1.4 and I was like okay still
not good when you're making a million a
month on a bad month then tell me I'm
wrong but I tell you something 10-year
plans are nonsense and if you're trying
to create a 10-year plan and thinking
you're going to be successful with a
10year plan then you're probably going
to be average and you're probably going
to be in a job till years old to it's
too long why do you think 10 year plans
nonsense lots of reasons one reason is
it's ridiculously long who the hell
knows what's going to be happening in 10
years look look at what you were like if
I look at what I was like 10 years ago I
couldn't even envisage what I'm doing
now in 10 years life is going to come
into play opportunities going to come up
that you could never predict 10 years is
a joke we work in quarters so we let me
just say this real quick as well this is
what I achieved in the last 10 months
lost five stone in weight published two
best-selling books created my own board
game established a property redress
scheme beat up Rob Moore and took his
100 Grand from him opened my own bank
Samuel Leeds Finance facility made2
million in Revenue bought my sister a
house cash got planning permission to
build over 50 new properties built a
hospital Ward built a school and bought
two hotels in 10 months you know people
are going to disagree with me oh no 10e
goals are really important patience is
really important Health before wealth
blah blah blah I don't think I've ever
set a 10-e goal in my life I think it's
nonsense well tell them how we set goals
so we do quarterly goals right every
goal we set we well we do we work on a
year-by-year basis but every broke down
into quarters so it's every is a year
yeah we see a year as a quarter and a
quarter as a year cuz this is the thing
right most people when they have yearly
goals even which I don't believe in have
a yearly goal it's too long what happens
is they slack off it's like when you
when you have a six week summer holiday
and you told to do your homework when
you do your homework you do it the last
few days yeah it's the same got 12 month
goal what happens in January yay
motivated and then and then come
September October you're like oh [__]
man I need to do that thing and do that
thing and then little push just before
Christmas little push before the end of
the year imagine if you had a three
month year what would happen is you
start the first month really good and
then you might have you have a little L
and oh it's almost ended and then the
last month push and then in those three
months you achieve more than you would
it most people and we we set like what
would be a yearly goal to most people we
do like our 10 year goals in a year I
think I do most people's 10 year goal I
do in three months most people say oh I
want to build a school one day 10 years
L you built that school yet no I built
two yeah but you're you're in a much wh
we're we're in a different playing field
today we got momentum and everything on
but some of the stuff like losing Five
Stone in 10 months learning to box I
mean these things they're nothing to do
with the fact that I'm wealthy no so
yeah long-term goals and nonsense also
with with with goals plan I believe in
plan it do it and review it and be
accountable we have a three Monon goal
but then we'll have a weekly
accountability means don't we yeah how
you getting on what's going down with
your goal what's happening how would you
score your you know your week this week
what three months pushes it makes it
happen it's amazing how much just having
to tell someone else where you're up to
holds you accountable as well yeah
especially when we got people like us so
what do you think do you disagree with
me do you disagree with Russell I'd love
to know what you think let us know in
the comments and I'll read every single
comment let me know when you're worth 20
million pound or more and then you'll
tell me that I was right